i
[Aplausos]
bueno qué tal buenas noches yo soy isaac
ezban guionista y director de cine tengo
tres películas el incidente es los
parecidos paralelas y otras más que
vienen en camino pero bueno más que
director de cine yo me considero a mí
mismo como un contador de historias de
hecho yo llego al cine por medio de las
historias así como hay mucha gente que
llega al cine más como por un tema de
cámaras o de postproducción o de de
equipo de lenguaje audiovisual yo lo que
me interesa más del cine es
qué es un gran medio para contar
historias y de hecho toda mi vida
siempre he contado historias y mis
películas son historias de ciencia
ficción es que cuando me invitaron a
este evento hablar de qué va a pasar en
el 2040 según mi profesión como yo
estaba emocional y ximo y dije no quiero
hablar solamente de qué va a pasar con
el cine en el 2040 sino que hablar de
qué va a pasar con las historias que
cómo vamos a contar historias en el
futuro pero antes de eso pues hay que
pensar que de hecho todos nosotros ya
contamos historias hoy todos los días no
quiero que piensen cuántas historias
contaban ustedes el día de hoy aquí por
lo menos cada uno de ustedes hoy con
todo 45 tal vez 10 historias cuando se
despertaron de contar una historia a
alguien después cuando estaban
desayunando le contar una historia a
alguien cuando hablan con su amigo con
su amiga con su pareja con sus hijos
contaron una historia todos los seres
humanos contamos historias todo el
tiempo entendemos el mundo a través de
historias y como bien dijimos en este
evento entre decks estamos aquí para
contar historias pero el ser humano de
cierta forma siempre ha contado
historias
épocas de antaño desde las pinturas
rupestres que contaban historias de
culturas de civilizaciones muy antiguas
y que son de cierta forma lo único que
queda que nos puede enseñar cómo
funcionan estas civilizaciones siguiendo
después con pues cuando nos sentábamos
en fogatas a contar historias y de hecho
esto es algo muy interesante el hecho de
que los humanos tenemos el poder de
creer en la ficción es lo único que nos
diferencia de otras especies si lo
piensan otras especies igual tienen
formas de comunicarse igual tiene
intelecto igual tiene muchas cosas más
pero el hecho que nosotros podemos creer
en ficciones es lo que nos hace ser
diferentes como especie y por eso
siempre hemos contado historias hemos
contado historias pues en la escritura
obviamente una vez que se inventa la
escritura pues podemos ya escribir cómo
están nuestras historias en la religión
contamos historias porque de hecho pues
las religiones son prácticamente
historias ficciones que nos creemos y
que le dan sentido a nuestras vidas en
la historia como tal del mundo al
escribir la historia del mundo la
escribimos y la recordamos
como una historia en la creación de
gobiernos al crear un gobierno de cierta
forma estamos creando una ficción un
país en el que todo el mundo cree es una
ficción en la pintura en la literatura
son medios expresión de contamos
historias y en el entretenimiento por
supuesto contamos historias y hoy vamos
a hablar mucho más de eso y hoy en día
pues seguimos contando historias en en
todos los medios en todas partes en la
publicidad contamos historias siempre no
cuando vemos una buena campaña de un
producto la publicidad nos está
vendiendo una historia para que nosotros
esa es la forma en la que accedemos a
ese producto en la cultura corporativa
cuando trabajamos en una empresa esa
empresa es una es un de cierta forma es
algo inventado es una ficción y que
nosotros nos creemos la historia de este
lugar y por eso formamos parte los
videojuegos los videojuegos cuentan
historias y por eso nos envuelven y de
hecho nosotros nos metemos a la historia
nos volvemos parte de la historia en un
videojuego la música cuenta historias
porque obviamente nosotros pues al
escuchar música esa música nos
imaginamos historias y además de eso nos
volvemos parte
la banda del artista y nos hablemos
parte de su historia
en la política en los países en el
nacionalismo como ya dije también el
nacionalismo de cierta forma es una
historia es un es una ficción que de
cierta forma nos metemos adentro en los
deportes la verdad es que yo aquí no soy
no soy muy fan de los deportes pero
estoy solo que muchos de ustedes sí y
sabrán que cuando existe el fanatismo
por un equipo eres parte de su historia
y cuando estás además viene un partido
pues eres parte de esa historia de una
historia que no sabes cómo va acabar y
bueno esto además lo quise meter porque
me contaron por ahí me chismean aunque
hoy hay un partido importante no sé que
ustedes que están aquí les importó mucho
venir a ver este evento a pesar está
viendo este partido así que quise
meterles un poquito de de fútbol por ahí
pero bueno en el arte obviamente
contamos historias el arte es un gran
medio de expresión donde donde contamos
historias y por supuesto en el cine en
la televisión en el entretenimiento
contamos historias en las redes sociales
contamos historias todos no de cierta
forma en las redes sociales es una es
una herramienta muy curiosa en la que
cada quien proyecta la historia de la
versión que uno cree que es pues la
versión que quiere proyectar al mundo
como uno quiere que lo perciban y de
cierta forma contamos nuestra historia
en todas las redes sociales pero el
lugar más importante donde contamos
historias es en la vida misma en la vida
misma en todas las conversaciones que
tenemos todos los días con toda la gente
y bueno
hablando un poquito de historia y de
como revoluciones tecnológicas han ido
transformando el mundo y han cambiando
como la como la tecnología ha ido
cambiando como conseguimos el mundo no
tuvimos pues cuatro revoluciones
industriales una en los 1700 que es la
revolución de pues el vapor de pronto
con el ferrocarril cambia el concepto de
distancias de cuánto hacemos de un lugar
a otro y de cierta forma cambia la vida
por completo no sólo alrededor del
ferrocarril sino cambiar muchas cosas de
la vida tenemos una segunda revolución
industrial que es de la electricidad
donde también cambian muchos conceptos
más en el 1800 el padre de los 1800
tenemos una tercera revolución
industrial que es la revolución de la
computación que empieza en 1960 por ahí
y acaba muy cerca de mil mil novecientos
noventa y tantos por ahí y en esta
revolución también cambia mucho pues las
cuestiones de privacidad de ética de
cómo trabajamos profesionalmente como
somos personalmente y tenemos la cuarta
revolución que la que vamos a vivir
ahorita en el 2016 que es de cierta
forma de la revolución de la
inteligencia la revolución que he hecho
que ahora
el asset más preciado que tenemos como
seres humanos son nuestros datos y es lo
más valioso y se predice que la
siguiente revolución industrial se va a
dar en el 2030 y va a ser la revolución
industrial de la singularidad que es lo
que todo el mundo estamos hablando de
como la inteligencia artificial de
pronto pues ya va a poder conocernos
mejor que nosotros mismos y va a poder
de cierta forma controlarnos controlar
que queremos o predecir muchas cosas
dense cuenta como todo cambia con estas
revoluciones industriales no cambia
obviamente pues la forma nuevos términos
nuevas dinámicas familiares nuevos
trastornos nuevas comunidades nuevos
sistemas educativos y obviamente también
cambia como contamos historias y también
cada vez va pasando menos tiempo entre
cada una de estas revoluciones así que
bueno la verdad es que yo no soy un
experto en este tema pero creo que es
importante tocarlo para tener un
fundamento de cómo la tecnología ha ido
cambiando en nuestra vida ahora sí
quiero hablarles
de lo que si yo me dedico y dedico mi
pasión día a día que es el tema de las
historias y para esto quiero enfocar
ahora esta parte de la plática ahora sin
más en el tema de las historias en el
entretenimiento es decir en el cine en
la televisión en la serie de televisión
que son cosas que todos los que estamos
aquí consumimos todos los días como
vamos a contar estas historias en el
futuro cómo vamos a disfrutar de estas
historias en el futuro para hablar de
esto quiero dividirlo en cuatro frentes
cuatro frentes que ya están vigentes hoy
en día en 2019 que son las experiencias
la inteligencia artificial los datos y
algoritmos el concepto de inmersión y el
concepto de descentralización vamos a
empezar primero con el concepto de
experiencias mucha gente me pregunta oye
exacto crees que en el futuro todavía
vamos a ir al cine teniendo ya pues
netflix y amazon y hb hoy el streaming
para ver lo que sea en mi casa yo creo
que 100% vamos a seguir yendo al cine
porque porque el ser humano es un ser
social necesitamos salir necesitamos
socializar necesitamos disfrutar de un
contenido fuera en nuestra casa con
seres queridos reírnos
sin embargo creo que va a cambiar mucho
la forma en la que vamos al cine ese
miedo de que ya no existía el cine ese
mismo vídeo que se tenía en los 50 es
cuando surgió la televisión y claro que
la gente siguió yendo al cine pero las
cosas cambiaron yo creo que en el futuro
vamos a ir al cine buscando dos tipos de
experiencias cada vez se va cómo dividir
más en que por un lado van existir estos
cines enormes que van a ser 14 de
llámenle 8 de 16 de cines en los que los
asientos van a volar y se van a mover
los personajes van a salir de la
pantalla y nos van a tocar y dónde vamos
a ver películas obviamente muy grandes
los pósters de hollywood con super
efectos especiales y superhéroes y
monstruos esta va a ser un tipo de
experiencia y el otro tipo de
experiencia va a ser cines clásicos
cines retro cines que de cierta forma no
usan otra experiencia la experiencia de
viajar al pasado y era un cine que te
sientes como si estás en un cine de los
50 por la marquesina y era un cine que
también el contenido es diferente un
cine donde vamos a ver películas más
quizás más independientes más autorales
más propositivas
extrañas más personales yo mismo también
soy uno de los fundadores del autocinema
coyote el primer y único auto cinema en
la ciudad de mexico en 35 años donde
justamente lo que nosotros ofrecemos al
público no es una película es una
experiencia la experiencia de viajar en
el tiempo era un autocinema como si
estuvieras en los años sesentas creo que
en el futuro y insisto todo esto tiene
fundamentos en lo que ya está pasando
hoy en día pero en el futuro que a veces
bifurcar más esto cada vez vamos a tener
estos dos extremos más separados de las
dos experiencias o la experiencia de que
voy a un cine que no es de ninguna marca
de franquicia que es un cine como más
artesanal digamos a ver una película
precisamente más artesanal no que use el
término de cine de arte pero vamos a
llamarle una película autoral
propositiva original interesante e
independiente y el cine que va a ser un
monstruo de ver películas súper
hollywoodenses y que pasa estos son dos
extremos que se van a ir enfocando y
todo lo que está en medio que son
muchísimas películas todo lo que esté en
medio lo vamos a ver en casa todo lo que
está en medio lo vamos a ver
nuestro sillón muy cómodos con unas
palomitas en algún servicio de streaming
y van a ser de cierta forma la mayoría
de las películas que no cupieron ni acá
ni allá entonces vamos a tener estas
tres experiencias muy divididas la
experiencia del cine espectáculo la
experiencia del cine autoral retro
artesanal y la experiencia del cine que
vemos en casa que va a ser enorme y si
lo piensan esto ya pasa hoy en día sólo
se va a acentuar ese es el primer
concepto el de experiencias vamos a ver
ahora el segundo concepto que es el de
inteligencia artificial datos y
algoritmos que pasa todos ustedes aquí
pues obviamente usan netflix usan amazon
usan archivo y se han dado cuenta como
de pronto ya netflix te dice nada porque
viste tal cosa ahora te pongo esto
porque te gustó esto ahora te pongo esto
digo a mí me pasa que me cuente netflix
está llena de parásitos que usted lo usa
gente hay que tiene la clave y que ya ni
sé quiénes son y el puente me sé por qué
viste esto tiene que ver pero nunca vi
eso aclaró si es la amiga de mi esposa
que se lo dio no es eso pasa mucho no
pero bueno de cierta forma
cómo se va todavía agudizar esto en un
futuro no piensen que las nuevas
generaciones ya no tienen este concepto
con el que nosotros crecimos de que ok y
vas a realizar una película y vas a
blockbuster de verdad la escogí así la
tenías en una caja y como ya les cogiste
la tienes que ver y si no te está
gustando las sigues viendo ahorita mi
hija que tiene 2 años
yo le trato poner una película y netflix
y estamos viendo finding nemo y a los 3
segundos me dice no no no adelantará en
la parte de las tortugas adelante en la
parte de los patos y yo de cierta forma
por un lado digo bueno tiene dos años
entiendo no como quiere la película
completa al mismo tiempo siento esta
frustración que digo híjole cómo va a
crecer esta generación que desde tan
temprana edad ya están acostumbrados a
que lo que quiero lo tengo ahorita en el
momento puede no terminar ninguna
película ahorita me está gustando está
después me gustar está como se va a
agudizar esto en el futuro cuando haya
un servicio de streaming ya no sé ni
siquiera si se va a llamar netflix si va
a ser
hb o amazon cuál va a ser el cual de
pronto va a saber lo que quieres y
quizás ya no solamente te va a poder
recomendar una película
qué va a pasar con incluso te pueda
crear una película en ese momento la
película que tú quieres ver de la crea
en ese momento especialmente para ti
ahora conviene en esto también con la
tecnología de efectos especiales que
pasa cada vez existen digamos la
animación cada vez tiene más más y más
herramientas para literalmente recrear
no solamente escenarios sino personajes
actores no sé si vieron esta película
del director israelí ari folman que se
llama the congress personas se las
recomiendo muchísimo es una gran
historia de ciencia ficción en la que
robin wright penn extra gran activista
interpreta a sí misma como una robert
wright penn que se quiere retirar y que
de pronto el estudio le dice si te
puedes retirar pero antes de retirar te
tienes que firmando este contrato donde
vamos a escanear todo tu cuerpo para que
de cierta forma tu imagen ya le
pertenezca al estudio y podamos tener te
como actriz por 100 años más siempre
conserva a la joven y tal cual en este
cuarto de luces la escanean y ella pues
termina dando su imagen a y no ahora de
cierta forma
parece una película de ciencia ficción
pero esto ya está pasando hoy en día y
no nada más teniendo que escanear el
actor es impresionante como hoy en día
en 2019 ya tenemos el poder de crear lo
que sea si todos aquí vieron rowan esta
precuela de star wars recreado una peter
cushing este actor que ya no está vivo
porque queríamos tener este momento esta
precuela de de cómo está él ahí en esta
mesa del imperio no siguiendo con el
tema star wars creo que cometió un error
muy interesante los creadores porque en
la nueva trilogía mataron a los
personajes clásicos cuyos actores y
siguen vivos a tan solo y a luke
skywalker y justamente dejaron viva a la
única personaje princess ley a que
lamentablemente la actriz que abrí
fisher si falleció en el mundo real oops
les acabo spoiler star wars bueno a ver
asumo que todos aquí ya vieron star wars
no esté diciendo aviones porque no les
interesa pero bueno aquí está un ejemplo
más como de como una gran historia que
nos une a todos y todos sabemos de lo
que estoy hablando no rápido y furioso
como requiera una paul walker
después de que falleció trágicamente
para que podía terminar la película y
para hacer todavía más más más actuales
de hoy en el momento pues espero que
hayan visto ya todos de arisman la nueva
obra maestra de martin scorsese donde
gracias a la tecnología podemos ver a
robert de niro y joe pesci desde que
tienen 40 años hasta que tienen 80 años
o por ahí no entonces ya existe la
tecnología para poder crear cualquier
actor ahora crucen estas dos cosas y
cómo va a existir ahora esta tecnología
para por un lado
netflix ya diga a ver le vamos a creer a
isaac una película que a él le gusta a
él le gustan películas de acción que le
gustan películas con brad pitt pero le
gusta brad pitt cuando tenía 40 años
pero le gusta además julia roberts
cuando tenía 40 años y pum pum pum pum y
a lo mejor al principio se va a tardar
todavía media hora o una hora avanza
tanques para que se descargue la
película pero después eventualmente va a
ser instantáneo no sé si esto va a ser
2040 más adelante le vas a poner play y
va a empezar a esta película no es
impresionante cómo se va a conectar esto
de la inteligencia artificial con los
algoritmos ahora esto nadie tiene
confirmado qué va a pasar pero yo pues
me imagino que va a pasar porque porque
está sustentado en cosas que están
pasando ya hoy en día el tercer concepto
que quiero hablar es el concepto de la
inmersión que hoy en día también existe
con la realidad virtual es impresionante
como este ejemplo la realidad virtual
berlín es una es una realidad virtual
donde literalmente simula como si
estuvieras volando en la ciudad de nueva
york obviamente pues no se recomienda
para para personas esté con vértigo no
porque el tram te estás pasando por los
edificios o llenos más algo
catatónico piar es un bear donde
literalmente vas por un asilo donde tu
eres un paciente y hay todos los otros
doctores o pacientes que se están
rodeando y no sabes que está pasando o
también el bear se usa mucho para
generar empatía como lo bien lo que hizo
soñar tu con carne y arena donde de
cierta forma tú eres un migrante que
está cruzando la frontera entonces
imagínense la combinación de ya los tres
conceptos no como también se puede
generar historias inmersivas y esto si
esto se puede generar hoy en 2019
imagínense lo que está por generar en
2040 y por último un concepto muy
importante es la descentralización a qué
me refiero con descentralización pues
todos tenemos una gran cámara en sus
bolsas no que no tiene aquí una super
cámara con la que ya podría grabar una
película antes las cámaras se dan estas
cosas inmensas con luces inmensas que
era muy difícil y muy caro puede hacer
una película hoy en día todos tenemos
las herramientas para ser una película
de cierta forma ya no tiene que venir de
un
gran estudio con muchísimo presupuesto
con una maquinaria enorme todos podemos
agarrar nuestro teléfono y lo que
importa hoy en día son las ideas si
tienes una buena idea puedes hacer una
película y no estamos hablando incluso
en buen el futuro películas que ya
existen por ejemplo tangerine de jean
baker una película que estuvo en
sundance
por ejemplo 11 en la nueva película
steven soderbergh que es una película de
suspenso muy especial que el mismo show
der berg la hizo con iphone o hablando
de la industria nacional por ejemplo oso
polar de marcelo tomaron una película
que ganó el festival de morelia hace un
par de años son cineastas que agarraron
y siendo una película con las
herramientas que tenían esto ya está
pasando hoy en día pasa en las redes
sociales también las redes sociales de
cierta forma han descentralizado y han
hecho que pues cualquier persona que
quiera dar información y tenga sus
seguidores no los youtubers los
influencers pues es algo muy interesante
y como esto ya se está monetizando hoy
en día y se va a monetizar todavía más
ahora combinemos los cuatro conceptos no
es uno otro otro otro yo creo que de
cierta forma podemos tener la
combinación de esta cuestión de la
inteligencia artificial con
esta cuestión de la inversión con esta
cuestión de la descentralización con
esta ocasión de las experiencias y como
todo va a estar combinado creo que esa
es la forma en la que nosotros vamos a
crear historias o consumir historias en
el 2040 o después suena quizás aterrador
suena como que la tecnología nos va a
controlar demasiado bueno para mí no
para mí suena muy emocionante para mí
tanto como consumidor como creador de
contenido creador de historias suena
impresionante tener todas estas
herramientas y quiero dejarlos con dos
conclusiones todavía más alentadoras de
lo que va a pasar la primera de ellas es
que a pesar de existir toda esta
tecnología yo voy a seguir contándole a
mi hija un cuento a todas las noches y
por cierto mi esposo está por ahí me
dijo hubieras puesto una foto de tu y tu
hija y en vez de poner una foto de un
cuate pelón yo dije bueno yo estoy medio
pelón también entonces creo que nos
tratan mal pero bueno de cierta forma
esto que tenemos los seres humanos de
contar historias verbalmente todos los
días ya sea así literalmente a nuestros
hijos antes de dormir
en donde sea en una llamada por teléfono
en una cita de trabajo o contar una
anécdota siempre va a seguir pasando
somos contadores natos de historias y la
tecnología no nos va a quitar eso ni
nada nos va a quitar eso siempre vamos a
seguir contando historias y la segunda
conclusión con la que los quiero dejar y
creo que esta sí es la más más
importante es que pues quiero decirles
un poco lo que yo le digo a mis alumnos
de cine aunque esto no aplica aquí
solamente para películas sino para
cualquier historia que vayan a crear si
hay alguien aquí en la audiencia a
alguien que nos esté viendo que de
cierta forma es un contador de historias
ya sea en cine en televisión que escribe
que es artista en música en de cualquier
forma está contando una historia lo más
importante es que las historias tengan
alma que sean personales en este futuro
en el que cada vez va a haber más y más
y más y más historias y cada vez más
gente va estar creando sus historias
imaginen si las y las historias son este
enorme deshuesadero de coches y existe
esta grúa que va agarrar una o si las
historias son esta máquina de peluche si
existe esta garra que va a agarrar una
esa historia la historia que va a
sobrevivir que va encontrar su público
van a ser las historias que tienen alma
que tienen algo que esa persona
específico nos podría contar que esa
persona tiene algo que decir
así que cierro con este mensaje que
siempre le digo a mis alumnos que es no
hagas la película que sabes que a ti te
va a quedar muy bien no no hagas esa
tampoco hagas la película que a ti te va
a quedar mejor que a los demás vaya
incluso no hagas la película que sabes
que tú eres el director perfecto para
hacer más bien haz la película que sólo
tú puedes hacer que si tú no existieras
esa película no existiría
si contamos historias que sólo nosotros
podemos contar esas historias van a
sobrevivir para siempre y con eso los
dejo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]